et pour en parler j'accueille williams
juillet avocat spécialisé en droit pénal
droit de l'homme et l'extradition
oublier bonjour je vous remercie d'avoir
accepté notre invitation direction arte
france on vient d'entendre le porte
parole de wikileaks depuis londres il
reproche à l'accusation de mentir sur
ses véritables intentions te ressources
publiques et sur l'information
de quel est votre regard qu'est ce que
vous en pensez alors c'est bien parce
que c'est une nouvelle idée qui commence
à être débattue on n'en avait pas
entendu beaucoup parler il me semble
jusqu'à maintenant le débat me
semble-t-il va tourner autour de la
question suivante est ce que julian
assange doit être protégé en qualité de
journalistes ou de travail fait en
relation avec le journalisme c'est la
protection des sources
on en dira peut-être un mot aussi c'est
la question des lanceurs d'alerté des
protections dont les lanceurs dallaire
peuvent bénéficier
et puis de l'autre côté il y à la
question de la défense de la sécurité
nationale et la défense d'un certain
nombre d'informations que des états
légitimement on peut le comprendre
considère comme devant être protégés
il ya eu d'ailleurs en cas des cas à
redon en france récent d'interpellations
d'audition de journalistes par la dgsi
notamment qui leur reprochaient ce qu'on
appelle en droit français la
compromission du secret défense
donc je crois que le débat qui arrive
maintenant à londres c'est celui de
savoir si on reproche à julian assange
d'avoir fait un travail de journaliste
ou si on lui reproche d'être allée au
delà c'est à dire d'avoir divulgué des
informations mettant en péril la ce la
sécurité nationale américaine et
éventuellement mettant en péril la vie
d'agent sur le terrain je crois que ce
débat avait eu lieu à une époque avec
des médias français notamment le monde
qui avait rompu sa collaboration avec
julian assange
considérant que la publication par lui
d'un certain nombre de documents sans
filtrage était contraire à leurs règles
déontologiques
alors vous le disiez les etats-unis lui
reprochent notamment ses activités
justement d'espionnage mais
juridiquement
un statut d' espions si je puis dire
absolument alors petite déformation
peut-être on parle d'espionnage en droit
français lorsque il y à la notion d'
intelligence avec une puissance
étrangère
6ème al qadam sedan alors à priori non
on est dans une problématique me semble
t'il juridiquement qui est plus proche
de celle que j'évoquais en droit
français on serait sur la compromission
du secret défense qui est une infraction
pénale tout de même grave alors passes
en 60 ou 100 et quelques années de
prison mais en droit français on en
cours tout de même cinq ans de prison et
en angleterre un texte a été voté il y a
peu qui permet de poursuivre des
individus qui auraient divulgué des
informations les ayant éventuellement
obtenu par le biais d'intrusion dans les
systèmes informatiques intrusion
illégale avec la des condamnations qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à la prison à vie si
jamais la publication des informations à
représenter une menace grave pour
l'ordre public anglais ou éventuellement
mis en danger de façon extrêmement
sérieuse des personnes et je crois qu'il
y à un débat sur le dossier assange à ce
niveau là qui n'a pas encore été
beaucoup évoqué mais je pense que les
choses vont se développer dans les
heures et les jours qui viennent en
relation avec cette discussion
on a également entendu joseph farrell
déclaré qu'il s'agissait je le cite
d'une répétition complète du procès de
chelsea
manning je le rappelle ancien analyste
militaire de l'armée américaine avait
été condamné en 2013 à 35 ans de prison
pour avoir transmis des informations à
wikileaks
qu'est ce que cette comparaison peut
nous dire justement de la manière dont
est mené le procès assange alors
peut-être on peut le prendre votre
question par par l'autre bout de la
réponse
chelsea manning a été en effet condamné
puis ensuite il y a eu une grâce
présidentielle qui a été décidé et puis
il a pu sortir de prison bien avant
l'heure parce qu'on a considéré qu'il y
avait peut-être tout de même aussi un
intérêt légitime à la publication d'un
certain nombre des documents qu'elle
avait fait sortir illégalement selon les
américains
alors est-ce que l'allusion au procès
chelsea manning est
raté gicm en opportune du côté de
wikileaks pour indiquer que ce procès-là
avait abouti à une condamnation mais
ensuite à une grasse je ne sais pas
c'est une possibilité
nous verrons où va l'argument il est
vrai que nous attendons tous de savoir
ce qui s'est passé dans la salle
d'audience aujourd'hui je pense que on
ne va pas tarder à avoir plus de
précisions et on verra dans les jours
qui viennent
voilà ce qui vient quand on tire sur ce
film pour conclure il nous reste
quelques secondes eric dupond moretti
l'un des avocats de julian assange va
déposer une requête de demande de droit
d'asile à emmanuel macron quelle parole
doit porter selon vous la france dans ce
dossier alors première question est ce
que c'est à emmanuel macron comporte une
demande d'asile juridiquement il ya en
france quelque chose qui s'appelle le
fera c'est une autorité administrative
indépendante
il est vrai que l'ayatollah communiste
s'était vu remettre semble-t-il le
statut de réfugié par le président
giscard en tout cas en 2020 il y à un
organe indépendant en france qui en
principe décide de si on peut se voir
octroyer le statut de réfugié on verra
la réponse de l'elysée sur ce point là
je sais qu'en 2009 quand je crois
françois hollande avait répondu à ce
courrier de julian assange en disant
qu'il n'y avait pas de menace imminente
juridiquement je je pense que il va
falloir revoir la réponse de l'elysée
on verra ce que la présidence d'un nous
dire merci beaucoup williams juliet
d'avoir apporté votre analyse je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat spécialisé
en droit pénal droit de l'homme et
d'extradition
merci